laiss tranquille sur la
dernière bonsoir bonsoir
bonsoir regardez bonsoir à tous oui oui
oui
regardez ce bel étalon oh pour le temps
que vous j'ai mis le smoking pour vous
ce soir oui ben je vous avez pas mis le
smoking c'est les indi d'or ce soir non
ind d'or in je l'ai vu hier la petite
fête on a fait une petite fête un petit
déjeuner chez H de e bureau au bureau
franchement on a bien rigolé on a bien
rigolé on a bien rigolé on a bien rigolé
ah ça oui tu as annoncé la prime ah ou
non pas pour vous ah d'accord salarié
d'âge de e ah c'est combien la prime
peux dire la prime
euh
combien pas mal 500 € tu leuras annoncé
sans savoir combien
c'était mais pas prévenu quand même
c'est alors le problème c'est que pour
tous les salariés pour tous les salarés
alors c'est très gentil un très beau
geste que vous avez fait pour les
employés en plus du en plus du robot et
de la console qu'on attend depuis 3 ans
euh très gentil tenlève ta prime non non
non alors non je vis vraiment vous
remercier pour cette prime
exceptionnelle cy que vous nous faites
chaque année non elle est
énorme
vra 500 pour
tout pour
les bravo
bravo vous étonnez pas que mes enfants
n' pas de cadeau à
Noël pas je VO déplacé en décapotable
votre fils la semaine dernière allez
dépêche-toi Tarba de l'année Tarba de
l'année on va commencer les catégories
puisque c'est les indi d'or on va
revenir sur toutes les séquences les
plus d'ca de cette saison avec vous
Ciril il va y avoir le fourir tapon
évidemment évidemment on commence avec
la première catégorie chaque chose on
s'entend c'est les tarbas de l'année
d'abord die sais qu' en a autour de
cette table on va pas se mentir c'est
pas la catégorie la plus compliquée à
monter les tarbas de l'année tout de
suite on
regarde dans la catégorie des tarbas de
l'année les nommés sont cyil Hanouna
c'est le style de Richard c'est vrai ah
commeit excuse-moi tu as une voix très
grave et ça m'
supporte Jean-Michel
mer essaie de trouver des idées des
idées géniales t émission des expéren
trouvent rien il regardent VO il
regardent mais même pas je P intitulé il
cherche un truc à écrire il cherche une
idée catastrophe catastrophe oh là là là
là
la police multiplie les saisies mais ça
ne sert à rien pour le moment le
phénomène est en expansion considérable
c'est le même problème que les
cigarettes les cigarettes clandestin
donc
merci je pas
intervenir encore cyil
Hanouna qu'est-ce qu'il y a
frro oh frère oh le bâtard
ça c'est la
personneée c'est la personne c'est la
personne on est d'accord c'est
canné ça fait ça fait ça fait 10 années
dessus que je le remporte ben bravo
félicitation félicitation chef
félicitations à mon avis vous allez
remporter beaucoup de catégories ce soir
on passe maintenant à ma catégorie
préféré perso ce sont les deanné
ceau des
fous G qui sont nor devent fous enant
sur ce plauf que les G monde extérieur
les invités parf il se demand qu'est-ce
qu'il fout là
deann dans la catégorie des de l'année
les nommés
son dans une deaise en train de samuser
le ça va ça va bien ça va ça va
ches vidéos ont immédiatementit Scand et
ont été visionné plusieurs millions de
fois beaucoup doutent de la véracité de
ces images Chantal Goya oui vous avez
déjà reconnu des anus bonsoir bah non
mais ce qui est vrai c'est que l'anus
c'est un peu comme la pupie de l'œil on
a personne n' le même anus c'est que
c'est un c'est on pourrait aller à
l'aéroport on pourrait très bien on
montre l'œil mais on pourrait très bien
montrer son anus à l'aéroport pour
passer la Douine parce que c'est c'est
plus
compliqué c'est une preuve irréfutable
il y a un nombre de plis ça fait comme
un C bar qui est ça va
Chantal comprend rien du tout une dame
dans le public pas
contente est en
réunion en train de se
lesbran il va sebran jusqu à quelle
heure en principe il est termine là midi
à
midi
[Applaudissements]
la dame la dame d la dame du
publicain jusqu'à midi on continue avec
un piège quiattendu mundir à Cyril et
très bizarrement cyril est tombé dedans
avec les chroniqueurs cette année alors
Mund fait croire à tout le monde qu'il
avait une idée d'émission géniale une
émission sur le poker présentée par
l'humoriste Roland mdan vousz vous vous
souvenez du nom de cette émission
branddan brand mdan regardez bien
comment c tombe dans le piège et les Van
que fait c sont très drôles aussi c'est
le prank de
[Musique]
l'année den est attribué à mundir
ZAR à vendrez vite de j'ai
mon tu connais Me' bien s il dit écoute
j'aimerais beaucoup faire quelque chose
avec toi au poker je écoute ça tombe
bien j'ai une émission le titre
[Musique]
BRD sur ma vie que ça va BR
unteur sur la vie de ma mère
moiantanimateur peux fairemission tu
peux produire et tout il tu connais
RD je va faire une émission sur le poker
et ça ser ch moi je suis animateurd et
tout et ça s'appellerit
BRD moi j'étais sur une émission de
coiffure et poker i Popp car
[Rires]
plong
é
[Applaudissements]
simpoupre
dit que c'est vrai le balancer mais non
parce que je croyais que c'était une
balle c'est pas une balle c'est pas une
balle je te don un truc tu vas leur
balancer laisse-moienvoyer le truc tu
regardes après si le titre t'intéresse
pas on change j'adore au contraire letre
c'est ce qu' a de mieux je te jure donc
là m avait envoyé un message à C en lui
disant qu'il était hyper vexé maisage
resta sans réponse bien sûr mais on a
poussé le prank en envoyant les
dirigeants de C8 vendre l'idée à Cyril m
très bien voilà
P merci beaucoup pour le non c'est vrai
tu vois c'est pas mal
AR non c'est
vraid à chaque fois mais je sais j'adore
BR MD
[Applaudissements]
j'adore je pense ça pourrait marcher je
ne rigole pas c'est pas complètement une
VAN c'est pas mal mais c'est l'idée est
pas nul l'idée est pas nul très
bien le truc ouais
allô ouais ça ça va qu'est-ce qui se
passe attends je te rappelle tout de
suite c'est un pote qui me dit qu'il a
réalisé une des plus belles affaires de
sa vie savoir ce que c'est il a eu la
votre prime peut-être c'est quoi c'est
pas 500 balles de prime00 ball de
PR enfin on passe à une catégorie qui
concerne un peu trop de monde sur ce
plateau je vous cache pas ce sont les
Charreaux de l'année alors en 2023
petite question qui a eu un peu trop
envie de tremper son biscuit je vous
donne un dis quelqu'un qui s'appelle
Jean qui finir par Michel ou encore un
certain Raymon je vous laisse regarder
ce sont les Charreaux de
l'année dans la catégorie des charau de
l'année les nommés sont Jean-Michel
mer vraimente derrière moi il y a une
bombe en vert regarde derrière moi
derrière moi tu as vu avec son mec avec
son
[Musique]
mec je te l'envoie alors attends attends
attends
comm du quoi quel contact Instagram
comme tu veux insta ouais WhatsApp
WhatsApp ouis Guillaume
Janton argentis
ma ok
ok depuis tout à l'heure j'assiste à un
petit spectacle Guillaume la
[Applaudissements]
Chine
il une baguette chaude dans
[Musique]
le
regard vous êes fait pour vous entendre
en fait ouais normalement
il ce soir je
qu ce soir
je alors à votre avis Ron pour vous Ron
sans
hésitationo techniqueement com trè relou
gagé tuas gagné le char de l'année la 5è
année consécutive Jean-Michel calme-toi
parce que tu es pas ouf non plus
là-dessus C année on a beaucoup de
séquences parce que tu as une Prim que
tu dois rester plus longtemps
on finit Cyril on finit avec notre
séquence préférée c'est j'étais obligé
de la montrer normalement c'est une
séquence qui passe que dans les
bêtisiers mais ici vu qu'on est dans une
émission de fou animée par un fou
produite par un fou et ben du coup on en
a toutes les semaines ce sont les fir
alors on en a eu des très très gros y
compris cette semaine on finit par les
fourir de
l'année dans la catégorie des fourir de
l'année les nommés sont Cyril Anouna pas
un extrait là que vous avez donné je
m'en irai on peut écouter Jean quand nos
yeux se regarderont comme des
choseses seront une évidence bien close
quand nos nudités lorsque nos vies ne
feront plus
c nous serons vraimentch commun je
m'en je te veux dans mon
équipe Cyril Hanouna donner quelques
conseils avec Lucas prouto qui est
spécialiste en défense an antiambriolage
alors on vous entend pas bien est-ce
qu'on entend bien monsieur
prouto [__] sans doute qui reste à
côté du domicile pour avoir vos heures
d'entrée et de sortie il repè j'avais
entendu dire qu'il y avait des gaz
dispersants c'est quoi des gaz
dispersants
monsieur et encore Cyril Hanouna on va
revenir sur cette
vidéo qui a fait un énorme boss ce
weekend après avec près de 5 millions de
vues en cumulé
s'il vous
plaît on va passervité du
[Musique]
soir oh là
là pe plus Géraldine c'est insupportable
on y voit donc Fran tapir qu'onadore ici
vient souvent nous
voir
magnifique incroyable salut cyil bonne
fête
merci élément pas bien mais c'est
beaucoup plus